-The President is in a standoff
with Congress
as some Democrats
call for impeachment.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump is defying
subpoenas from Congress.
His attorney general threatened
not to show up
to hearings this week,
and several Democrats
have called on Congress
to begin the process
of impeachment.
So Trump has a lot going on,
which means, of course,
that he decided to take time
out of his schedule
to call in to a Fox morning show
and once again spent
so much time on the phone
that at the end
of the interview,
the host, Maria Bartiromo,
repeatedly tried to get him
to hang up.
-Everybody wants people
to go out
and find out
what the hell happened,
where did all
of this corruption start.
When you have --
-Well, certainly our viewers
want to know.
-The lovers, we call them.
-Yeah, our viewers
want to know that.
-Saying, "We want
an insurance policy."
-Mr. President,
thank you so much.
-"...Hillary Clinton loses.
We want an insurance policy
where we can get Trump out."
Well, it didn't work so well.
But I'll tell you what,
it really hurt our country,
and it hurts our country.
These people are corrupt.
-Yeah.
-And then you look at a guy
like Brennan with his big mouth.
But it's a disgrace.
Everyone wants to know, Maria,
and you might be number one
on the list.
I watch your show.
You're incredible.
You may be number one
on the list.
Everybody wants to know,
"How did it start?
Why did it start?
What about the dossier?"
-Well, we want to know.
-How much did Hillary Clinton
pay for the dossier?
You know she paid for it.
You know, everybody
wants to know about it.
And that's really -- Hopefully
they'll be going there.
-My God, that was like
watching your grandpa
try to get off the phone
with his grandpa.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
She ran out of minutes
on her plan.
He's like one of those guys
who calls a restaurant
to place an order for delivery
and then tries to have
a conversation with the staff.
"Yeah, I'll take
a large pepperoni,
and, hey, what's your name?
You always been interested
in pizza?"
I know it's hard
to remember this sometimes,
but that guy is the most
powerful man in the world.
He should be, like, doing stuff.
And Maria knows.
I mean, look at her face.
That's the face you make
when your friend says,
"I want to set you up
with a guy.
He's a count."
And then halfway
through the dinner,
you realize she meant
he can count.
[ As Donald Trump ]
Oh, I know them all.
One, two, three.
Can't live without that number.
[ Normal voice ] But aside
from rambling incoherently
about whatever
he was rambling about,
Trump also repeated
the dangerous line
he's been using lately
about the investigation
of him and his campaign --
that it was an attempted coup
and the people behind it
were traitors.
He used it in the interview
with Bartiromo
and repeated it in speeches
and interviews
over the last few weeks.
-This was an attempted coup.
This was an attempted takedown
of a president,
and they got caught.
And what they did was treason.
This was really a coup attempt.
-It's all quite extraordinary,
Mr. President.
-It didn't work.
We caught them.
-Yeah.
-They tried for a coup.
Didn't work out so well.
This was a coup.
This was an attempted overthrow
of the United States government.
-So, there you go.
That's what the President said.
This was a coup,
and the people who
orchestrated it were traitors.
And of there's anything
Trump hates, it's traitors
who try to overthrow
the United States government.
-There were very fine people
on both sides.
-Oh, I've answered
that question.
And if you look at what I said,
you will see that that question
was answered perfectly.
And I was talking
about people that went
because they felt very strongly
about the monument to
Robert E. Lee, a great general.
Whether you like it or not, he
was one of the great generals.
-First of all, no, he wasn't.
He led an armed rebellion
to bring down the United States
government and he lost.
In other words...
-They tried for a coup.
Didn't work out so well.
-And on top of that --
on top of that --
Can't believe we have to
keep saying this,
but your response to
Charlottesville was not perfect.
There were no very fine people
on both sides.
There were literal
white supremacists shouting,
"Jews will not replace us."
And they were carrying
tiki torches,
which is something
we will never forget,
because now
when you buy a tiki torch,
you have to go out of your way
to say,
"We're having a barbecue!
It's for barbecue stuff."
But, of course,
Trump couldn't just stop
at heaping praise
on a traitorous general
who defended slavery
and tried to bring down
the United States government.
He also had to heap some praise
on himself.
-Mr. President, how old
is too old to be president?
-Well, I think that
I just feel like a young man.
I'm so young!
I can't believe it.
I'm the youngest person.
I am a young, vibrant man.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe I have to
say this, but we can see you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I mean, what are we...
even supposed to do
with that information?
That's a 72-year-old
president of the United States,
a man who spends most
of his time watching cable TV
and riding around in a golf cart
and stands like he's in
"Weekend at Bernie's."
I mean, here he is
at his golf club recently
with fellow lumpy grandpa
Rush Limbaugh.
Look at that.
It's like an episode
of "Star Trek"
where a transporter malfunction
creates a second Trump.
[ Laughter ]
And in case defending
Robert E. Lee
or calling himself a young,
vibrant man wasn't enough,
Trump also made a bunch
of public appearances where,
as usual,
sounds came out of his mouth
that sounded vaguely
like human words.
-Look, it's a rigged system,
okay?
If I told you how crazy it is,
the web -- It's a web.
You need 193 IQ
to even understand.
This web of geniuses, they put
this thing to lower drug price.
It has 19 effects here and 27.
We got it down, and we're
getting it down further.
We have the smartest people,
the best people in that world
working on it.
This treaty
threatened your subjugate.
And you know exactly
what's going on here.
Your rights.
I always say this, because
as good as that equipment is --
and it's genius --
the greatest equipment
in the world is a dog.
Dogs, a certain type of
German shepherd in particular.
Dogs do a better job than
$400 million worth of equipment.
-I mean, good Lord, it's like
getting cornered at a party
by a guy who's almost
run out of cocaine.
"I use a dog, though.
That's what I use."
The only thing that's impressive
about Trump
is that the range of subjects
he rambles about
gets wider and wider every day.
Most of the time he'll say
the same stuff over and over
about building a wall
or crooked Hillary or fake news.
But once in a while
he'll mix in something
totally bat[bleep] crazy
like smart dogs with high IQs
or whatever the hell
he was talking about.
Honestly, there's a good chance
someone switched his Fox News
to an episode of "Wishbone"
and he thought it was real.
[ As Donald Trump ] You have to
see this dog -- so smart.
Solving mysteries.
[ Normal voice ] Also -- Also...
can we...
can we hear the crowd reaction
to that line?
-The greatest equipment
in the world is a dog.
Dogs...
[ Scattered applause ]
...a certain type of
German shepherd in particular.
-The weirdest thing
about being at a Trump speech
is those moments you have to
hesitantly clap
for stuff you know
you don't understand.
"Yeah, dogs.
Yeah, the best equipment's
a dog, right?
We didn't elect
a [bleep] maniac, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah."
As all this dumb stuff
keeps happening,
it's impossible to remember
that Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's final report
came out
less than two weeks ago,
and it confirmed much of what we
already suspected about Trump,
including the fact
that he and his team
openly welcomed
the help of Russians
seeking to interfere
in the election
and repeatedly lied about it
and tried to interfere
in the investigation of it.
We've basically known that
for two years,
but now we have
a 400-page report to prove it.
I mean, even the page count
looks bad for Trump.
If you hired a private detective
to find out if your wife
is cheating
and he sent you 400 pages,
you wouldn't even read them.
You'd go straight
to your lawyer's office.
Like, "Chad has
his own section!"
And let's remember the report
specifically listed 10 times
Trump may have
obstructed justice.
And Mueller's team even went out
of their way to say explicitly
that they could not
exonerate them.
Instead, Mueller specifically
turned it over to Congress.
-While Mueller stopped short
of taking a position
on obstruction,
his words suggest Congress
now has a role to play.
He writes, "We concluded
that Congress has authority
to prohibit a president's
corrupt use of his authority
in order to protect
the integrity
of the administration
of justice."
-This is from
the Mueller report.
The conclusion that Congress
may apply the obstruction laws
to the President's corrupt
exercise of the powers of office
accords with our constitutional
system of checks and balances
and the principle that no person
is above the law.
-It's amazing Trump
and his supporters
are celebrating this
as an exoneration
when Mueller keeps hinting
that Congress could take actions
that were unavailable
to Mueller.
For example, in Footnote 574,
Appendix B, Subsection 48C,
Mueller writes...
[Coughing] impeachment.
[ Laughter ]
The facts couldn't have been
any clearer in Mueller's report.
Congress has the authority
to investigate Trump
for obstruction of justice
and hold him accountable for it.
This is why we have
a Congress --
to reign in a lawless president.
You have all the evidence
you need.
But if you still want to find
more evidence, just remember...
-The greatest equipment
in the world is a dog.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]